après s'être mutuellement accusés d'être
responsables du blocage dans le pays
michel aoun et saad hariri se sont
finalement rencontrés ce jeudi le
premier ministre désigné a ensuite pris
la parole
saad hariri a assuré qu'il souhaite la
formation rapide d'un gouvernement pour
redonner confiance à la population
l'objectif principal de ce gouvernement
qui doit être formé le plus vite
possible et de donner l'espoir aux gens
et d'arrêter l'effondrement de la livre
libanaise saad hariri a rappelé qu'il
penchait pour un gouvernement de
technocrates comprenant 18 ministre
hassan nasrallah à la tête du sb là
c'est lui aussi exprimé le chef du
mouvement chiite a dit espérer la
formation d'un gouvernement formé de
technocrates mais aussi de politiciens
les forces politiques devraient assumer
avec vous cette responsabilité et former
un gouvernement technopôle itic si c'est
possible afin de nous assurer que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités un
gouvernement également appelée de ses
voeux par la france dans la tente de la
mise en place de réformes pour sortir de
la crise
emmanuel macron a estimé qu'un
changement d'approché était nécessaire
dans le pays
le temps des responsabilités en tout cas
du test de responsabilité s'achève et
qu'il nous faudra dans les prochaines
semaines de manière très claire sans
doute changer la proche les méthodes car
nous ne pouvons laisser depuis août
dernier le peuple libanais dans la
situation où il est
l'impasse politique s'ajoute à un
contexte de grave crise économique
les libanais font face à une explosion
du chômage
d'après l'onu plus de la moitié de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
les tensions se sont exacerbées depuis
les explosions dans le port de beyrouth
en août dernier elles ont entraîné la
destruction de plusieurs quartiers de la
capitale